In this lecture we're going to talk
about how to instantiate vector space
model so that we can get a very
In this lecture, we are going to talk about how to instantiate vector space model so that we can get a very specific ranking function.
So this is to continue the discussion
of the vector space model, which is one
particular approach to design ranking
function.
And we're going to talk about how we
use the general framework of the vector
space model as a guidance to
instantiate the framework to derive a
specific ranking function.
And we're going to cover the simplest
instantiation of the framework.
So as we discussed in the previous
lecture, the Vector Space model is
really a framework.
It didn't say.
As we discussed in the previous
lecture.
Vector space model is really a
framework.
It doesn't say many things.
So for example, here it shows that it
did not say how we should define the
dimension.
It also did not say how we place a
document vector in this space.
It did not say how we place a query
vector in this vector space.
And finally, it did not say how we
should measure the similarity between
the query vector and the document
vector.
So you can imagine in order to
implement this model
we have to say,
specifically, how we compute these
vectors?
What is exactly Xi and what is exactly
Yi?
This will determine where we place a
document vector, where we place a
query vector.
And of course, we also need to say
exactly what should be the similarity
function.
So if we can provide a definition of
the concepts that would define the
dimensions and these Xi's or Yi's,
namely weights of terms for query
and document,
then we will be able to
place document vectors and query
vector in this well defined
space and then if we also specify
similarity function then we'll have a
well defined the ranking function.
So let's see how we can do that and
think about the simplest
instantiation.
Actually, I would suggest you to pause the
lecture at this point, spend a couple
of minutes to think about.
Suppose you are asked to implement this
idea.
You come up with the idea of vector
space model.
But you still have to figure out how to
compute these vectors.
Exactly how to define the similarity
function?
What would you do?
So think for.
A couple of minutes and then proceed.
So let's think about the some
simplest ways of instantiating this
vector space model?
First,
how do we define dimension where the
obvious choice is to use each word in
our vocabulary to define the dimension?
And here we show that there are N
words in our vocabulary,
therefore there are N dimensions.
Each word defines one dimension and
this is basically the bag of words
representation.
Now let's look at how we place vectors
in this space.
Again here the simplest
strategy is to
use a bit vector to represent both the
query and a document.
And that means each element Xi and Yi
would be taking a value of either zero
or one.
When it's one, it means the
corresponding word is present in the
document or in query. When it's zero it's
going to mean that it's absent.
So you can imagine if the user types in
a few words in the query, then the
query vector will only have a few ones,
many many zeros.
The document vector in general
will have more ones of course.
But it will also have many zeros, since
the vocabulary is generally very large.
Many words don't really occur in
any document.
Many words will only occasionally occur
in the document.
A lot of words will be absent in a
particular document.
So now we have placed
the documents and the query in the
vector space.
Let's look at how we
measure the similarity.
So a commonly used similarity measure
here is dot product.
The dot product of two vectors
is simply defined as the sum of the
products of the corresponding elements
of the two vectors.
So here we see that it's
the product of X1 and Y1.
So here.
And then X2 * Y2 and then finally XN
multiplied by YN and then we take a
sum here.
So that's the dot product.
Now we can represent this in a more
general way using a sum here.
So this is only one of the many
different ways of measuring the
similarity.
So now we see that we have defined the
the dimensions we have defined the
vectors and
we have also defined the similarity
function, so now we finally have
the simplest of vector space model.
Which is based on the bit vector
represntation dot product similarity
and bag of words representation.
And the formula looks like this.
So this is our formula, and that's
actually particular retrieval function,
a ranking function,
right? Now we can find the implement
this function using a programming language
and then rank documents for query.
Now at this point you should again
pause the lecture.
So think about how we can interpret
this score.
So we have gone through the process of
modeling the retrieval problem.
Using a vector space model and then we
make assumptions
about how we place vectors in the
vector space and how we define the
similarity.
So in the end that we've got a specific
retrieval function,
shown here.
Now the next step is to think about
whether this retrieval function
actually makes sense.
Can we expect this function to
actually perform well when we used to
rank the documents for users' queries?
So it's worth thinking about.
What is this value that we'll calculate?
So in the end we get a number, but what
does this number mean?
Is it meaningful?
So spend a couple of minutes to think
about that.
And of course the general question here
is:
Do you believe this is a good ranking
function would they actually work?
So again, think about how to interpret
this value. Is it actually meaningful?
Does it mean something?
It's related to how well the document
matches the query.
So in order to assess whether this
simplest vector space model actually
works well, let's look at the example.
So here I show some sample documents
and a simple query.
The query is news about the
presidential campaign and we have 5
documents here.
They cover different terms in the
query.
And if you look at the these documents
for a moment,
you may realize that
some documents are probably relevant
and some others are probably non
relevant.
Now, if I ask you to rank these
documents
how would you rank them?
This is basically our ideal ranking:
when humans can examine the documents
and then try to rank them.
So think for a moment and take a look
at this slide and perhaps by
pausing the lecture.
So I think most of you would agree that
d4 and d3 are probably
better than others because they really
cover
the query well.
They match news, presidential and
campaign.
So it looks like these documents
are probably better than the others, so
they should be ranked on top.
An the other three D2, D1, and D5 are
really non relevant, so we can also say
differently.
D4 and D3 are relevant documents and D1, D2,
and D5 are non relevant.
So now let's see if our simplest
vector space model could do the same or
could do something closer.
So let's first think about how we
actually use this model to score
documents.
Right here I show 2 documents D1
and D3 and we have the query
also here. In the vectors space model
of course we want to 1st compute the
vectors for these documents and the
query.
Now I show the vocabulary here as well,
so these are the N dimensions that
will be thinking about.
So what do you think is the vector
representation for the query?
Note that we are assuming that we only
use zero and one to indicate whether
the term is
absent or present in the query or in
the document, so these are 0/1 bit
vectors.
So what do you think is the query
vector?
The query has four words here, so for
these four words there will be one and
for the rest will be 0.
Now, what about the documents? It's the
same, so T1 has two words news and
about.
So there are two ones here and the rest
of zeros.
Similarly.
So.
Now that we have the two vectors.
Let's compute the similarity.
And we're going to use dot product so
you can see when we use dot product we
just multiply the corresponding
elements, right?
So these two will be.
forming,
forming product and these two will
generate another product and these two
will generate yet another product and so
on so forth.
Now you can easy to see if we do that.
We actually don't have to care about.
These zeros.
Because if whenever we have zero the
product will be 0.
So when we take a sum over all these
pairs
then
the zero entries will be gone.
As long as you have 1 zero then the
product will be 0.
So in effect we're just counting how
many
Pairs of one and one, but in this case
we have seen two, so the result would
be two.
So what does that mean?
Well, that means this number or the
value of this scoring function is
simply the count of how many unique
query terms are matched in the
document.
Because if a document, if a term is
matched in the document, then there
will be 2 ones.
If it's not then there will be 0 on
the document side.
Similarly, if the document has a term,
but the term is not in the query, there
will be a zero in the query vector, so
those don't count.
So as a result this scoring function
basically
matches how many unique query terms are
matched in the document.
This is how we interpret this score.
Now we can also take a look at the D3.
In this case
you can see
the result is 3 because
D3 matched three distinct
query words: news, presidential, campaign.
Whereas D1 only match two. Now
in this case, it seems reasonable to
rank D3 on top of D1 and
this simplest vector space model indeed
does that, so that looks pretty good.
However, if we examine this model in
detail, we likely will find some
problems.
So here I'm going to show
all the scores for these five
documents.
And you can easily verify their correct
because
we're basically counting the number of
unique query terms matched in each
document.
Now note that this matching actually that
makes sense, right?
It basically means if a document
matches more unique query terms then
the document will be assumed to be more
relevant, and that seems to make sense.
The only problem is here we can notice
that there are three documents D2, D3, and D4 and they
tied with a 3
as a score.
So that's a problem, because if you
look at them carefully, it seems that
D4 should be
ranked above D3 because D3
only mentioned presidential once, but
D4 mentioned it multiple times.
In the case of D3 presidential,
could be an extended matching.
But D4 is clearly about the
presidential campaign.
Another problem is that
D2 and D3 also have the same score.
But if you look at the three words that
are matched in the case of D2
it matched the news, about, and campaign.
But in the case of D3, it
matched news, presidential, and
campaign.
So intuitively D3 is better
because matching presidential is
more important than matching about even
though about and presidential above in
the query.
So intuitively, we would like D3
we ranked above D2.
But this model doesn't do that.
So that means this model is still not
good enough.
We have to solve these problems.
To summarize, in this lecture we talked
about how to instantiate a vector space
model.
We may need to do three things.
One is to
define the dimension.
The second is to decide how to place
documents as vectors in the vector
space.
And to also place a query in the vector
space as a vector.
And 3rd
is to define the similarity between two
vectors, particularly the query vector
and the document vector. We also talk
about a very simple way to instantiate
vector space model.
Indeed, that's probably the simplest
vector space model that we can derive.
In this case, we use each word to define a
dimension.
When user 0/1 bit vector to represent a
document or a query.
In this case, we basically only care
about word presence or absence.
We ignore the frequency.
And we use the dot product as the
similarity function.
And with such a instantiation, and we
showed that the scoring function is
basically to score a document based on
the number of distinct query words
matched in the document.
We also show that such a such simple vector
space model still doesn't work well and
we need to improve it.
And this is a topic that we're going to
cover in the next lecture.